for the GSP fight like I would make sure
I paid everybody back any money I owed
if I borrowed a book or a CD or whatever
I'd make sure they were returned you
know I'd make sure that everything was
taken care of because that 25 minutes is
my last 25 minutes and it has to be
because because otherwise I'm not going
to compete to my potential if I'm not
prepared to give everything it's War it
can't be anything other if you treat it
like a sport you're going to lose every
time what do you make about slap I'm
sort of like going wait like I
understand people hitting each other and
being able to defend each other but this
is just people hitting each other
just with no protection is that really a
sport
but what do you make of it it's
dangerous it's very very dangerous but
now again I feel like Dana feels like
he's Untouchable because they are
ramming the power slap League down our
throats so it's a lining basically two
guys just taking three swings at one
another like it's just it's CTE for
money like they're trading brain cells
for cash
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
guest today is a former UFC title
Contender MMA commentator analyst and
now fellow YouTuber with his channel uh
full reptile Dan Hardy welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much guys
thank you mate it's so great to have you
on I'm a big fan of your of your
analysis I watch all your breakdowns of
the UFC fights
um as I said to you this is a bit of a
different tag for us because we are
normally talking about culture and
politics and stuff but we're super
excited to have you some of our audience
won't know who you are what's your
journey through life like how are you
here what what what have you been up to
um I mean basically martial arts all the
way through I started when I was six
um and I just I never stopped started
with Taekwondo and trained all the way
through into my teens my grandfather
started when I was in my early teens so
I was able to train with him for a few
years and that kind of kept me focused
in those those years when you kind of
wander off and start getting distracted
with things
um and then I did art college and then
University for a couple of years doing
Contemporary Art and it was fun it was a
lot of a lot of time to kind of think
about myself and where I wanted to go
with my life but ultimately I wanted to
do martial arts but the UFC was a very
new thing back then and there wasn't
really an option for me to be a
professional in any way other than being
a coach so I kind of I felt like that
was meant my destiny I was going to be a
martial arts teacher and then as the UFC
started to grow I started to compete in
amateur events and Muay Thai and
whatever else I could find that was you
know Combat Sports basically anything
that I could get a fight I would do it
um and that that led me to professional
MMA I made my Pro debut 2004
um at a busy first year I think I have
14 fights in my first year wow yeah I
was I was quite busy in the early years
because I I always found it easier to
stay in shape than get in shape you know
so sometimes I go to an event and
there'd be a spare opponent so I'd have
a couple of fights on the same night you
know just to get more experience and and
I moved through the UK scene pretty
quickly
um then I signed with the UFC made my
debut in 2008
um and I was with the UFC for well four
five years as a competitor had 10 fights
managed to fight for the world title as
you said Joe sent Pierre one of the
Grammy you fought one of the best
fighters in the history of the UFC right
and it felt like it
yeah there's a long 25 minutes of
questioning where my life was going to
go after this point if I'm honest he was
very very good very slick great great
conditioning uh you know just a very
smart individual very dedicated to his
sport it was an honor to be able to
fight him um but then after that it all
kind of fell apart I came back to uh
London fought the Auto Arena and got
knocked out in the first round that was
not very pleasant
um still kind of funny to think about it
now you know you you know desensitize
yourself to it but it was a big setback
at the time because I felt like I was
going to be back on the title Road
pretty quickly and then I fought a giant
next Anthony Johnson lost to him by
decision and then I just threw the next
fights away just being Reckless so I
kind of felt like I'd gone four wins
into my professional UFC career and then
four losses and I thought that was going
to be it for me unfortunately the owner
at the time Lorenzo Fertitta said that
he was going to keep me around so I got
got two more fights won them both
um and then I was I was sidelined with a
medical concern and you could say it was
a an irregular heartbeat but it was I
mean it never caused me any problems it
it stopped me competing for a number of
years which was frustrating but it also
allowed me to kind of sidestep into
commentary and that's really where I
probably have found my skill which is
analysis I loved fighting but it was
always more difficult for me than my
teammates they were always better
athletes or you know more dedicated more
skilled more focused whatever it was and
I always struggled whereas because I had
to solve problems with my brain all the
time it kind of It kind of prepared me
for a job as an analyst so then I
commentated for the UFC for a number of
years parted ways with them now due to
various different political reasons
um and now I've just signed a contract
with a new organization which I'll be
I'll be doing a lot of work with the pfl
so uh yeah and we're also in training
camp my wife's fighting UFC London in
March so that's that's keeping us busy
got a couple of gyms up in the Midlands
lots of things going on but all MMA
focused yeah yeah and uh one of the
things that you raise I mean we'll talk
about all sorts of different stuff but
one thing I always want to know when you
see these guys squaring off and they're
both I'm Gonna Knock You and no I'm
gonna and you're going I mean one of
them probably thinks the other one is
better don't they like when you're
fighting George Saint Pierre is there a
bit of like you're walking into it
knowing you're gonna get your ass kicked
a little is that does that happen yes
absolutely it does absolutely because
you know the thing is sometimes when you
when you're facing someone that is I
mean he'd been the champion for a number
of years so he'd already positioned
himself he got you know good money
coming into Direction he was able to set
up his training camps well he had a good
team of people around him and I mean I I
just felt like I didn't have the
resources or the people around me to
really be competitive but of course I'm
not going to turn the opportunity down
um so it was it was just about doing my
best and the reality is I'm a striker so
in the back of my head I can always land
that one shot that's going to put my put
them away
so I did feel like at one point in the
fight I might be able to connect with
something and knock him out but he's
just such a good wrestler he's you know
so smart and he was very respectful of
my striking which means he didn't really
let me do any of it
um so it was a it was a frustrating
fight but it was it was a big learning
experience for me as well and you know
it and I guess the bigger challenge was
going forward and picking up several
more losses and trying to stay on track
that's the biggest problem for the
biggest difficulty I think is a
professional because
of course everything is about winning
and you you build your identity around
the person that people see in the in the
cage and if that person keeps getting
their ass kicked it's you know not quite
don't have the same kind of presence as
you would like Dan I interviewed uh
dillian what a few years ago and I asked
him what's the most terrifying thing for
an opponent to have over you is it a
devastating left hook is it combinations
is it the fact that they're just going
to keep on going and he said no it's
looking over to your opponent at the
other corner of the ring and realizing
that he's crazy is that true yeah yeah
that's absolutely true yeah absolutely
true and and you know sometimes
sometimes Fighters are smart enough to
be able to realize this advantage and
create the advantage for themselves I I
will always smile I'll always smile in
the corner I'll always you know get
punched in the face and grin at my
opponent I want them to feel like I'm
crazy I want them to feel like they can
push and push and push and at no point
I'm gonna I'm gonna decide to quit and
and I think that's where that's the
crazy part is knowing you've got
somebody in front of you that's not
going to quit you're going to have to
put them away
um because that's easier said than done
you know sometimes you can put somebody
away easier if they've already checked
out of the fight themselves if you've
pushed them and you've beat them up and
you've worn them out a lot of people a
lot of people will just decide they
don't want to be there anymore and then
you get the occasional crazy person that
will not go away and and I I tried to
model myself on that person I wasn't
always but uh I hope I left that lasted
impression with at least some of my
opponents and Dan
most people I love UFC I love boxing
I've Loved boxing since I was eight
years old watching Mike Tyson that was
my era growing up but I never wanted to
be a fighter most people when you say to
them would you like to be a boxer a UFC
fighter even if they love the sport
they'd be like no way what is it that
makes someone want to get in that ring
and fight
um I mean I think it's it's just a
particular character type I think some
people are more like in the in their in
their hearts and in their minds anyway
and I feel like I mean certainly for me
competition fight competition is the
only time that my brain just goes silent
it's the only time I am I am solely
focused on one thing all of the rest of
the time I'm thinking about a variety of
different things but that that peace and
quiet that I get when I'm in competition
and it sounds odd because it's a very
chaotic environment but I think it's
because it's so chaotic I'm drawn to it
because it's it's kind of peaceful in a
way because it gives me a a single Focus
um I mean that for me was was the
biggest thing and the other thing as
well is I mean I was never much of a
team sport player because I don't like
to have to rely on other people to pull
their weight I I played rugby and
football and I was never very good at
them but neither of my teammates
I I preferred something where the
pressure's on me you know that the
weights on my shoulders to perform
um and you know there's an adrenaline
rush to it it's a very very addictive
adrenaline rush you know like of course
as a kid I'd get into a few fights and
growing up going to rock city and
Nottingham of course you're getting a
few fights there as well and you like
that adrenaline but it's
the thing that always disconnected me
from that is the consequence right you
can't get into a fight and feel like you
can just let go like I always had to
feel like I was holding back and when
you go into a fight and I'm standing
across someone that has prepared to beat
me like their their goal is to is to
take me out it allows me to take the
pressure off myself and just go at them
with full force
um and that's quite a unique experience
something I've not I've not experienced
in any other any other format or
capacity because Tyson spoke about it in
his documentary there's this really
powerful Montage where he goes before I
go into the ring I'm terrified my hands
are shaking I don't know I can't speak I
just want to run away I don't know what
to say and my hands are shaking my my my
back sweating and then I step into the
ring and I become a god
did you kind of feel that that you just
walk the moment you cross that octagon
you become a different person that's you
tap into something else yes yeah
absolutely and I think it was a bit more
obvious for me because especially people
that know me away from competition you
know I'm relatively quiet I like my own
space I'm not very much of a public
person I don't really like to be out
amongst amongst people but then you see
my character when I'm competing in the
UFC and people would assume I'm an
extrovert I've got red here come out
with a bandana you know interacting with
Bruce Buffer you know staring at my
opponents but and that definitely is a
part of who I am but it's it's like I've
found a facet of my personality and I've
turned the volume right up on it and
that person is a maniac
and the thing is I know that that's
within me like I feel it sometimes when
I'm on the M25 and I'm like there's the
maniac calm down calm down but in that
area in that in that situation I can
just I can let it breathe and I it's
it's quite a it's quite a relief to be
and of course you know I everything that
Tyson said is correct you know the walk
out this this fear this you know you're
terrified you're anxious because of
course you know there's the possibility
of getting injured but there's the
possibility of losing that's the that's
the thing that I was most afraid of not
performing not stepping in there and
doing everything that I knew I was
capable of and that really was the the
main hold up for me
um like the fight itself is
you roll the dice and you see what
happens it's interesting how the I mean
this just to be very clear because
people will misrepresent this but I was
going to say how similar what you're
describing is to the process of doing
stand-up because and people will come up
to you and go you're so brave I mean I
think you're a lot braver but oh no I
would disagree I would disagree because
I know what's expected of me if I'm
stepping into a fight all I have to do
is throw down when you walk onto a stage
people expect you to make them laugh and
that is a very very very tall task
I've always thought to myself like of
all the things that I would take on
because I've I was in bands I've
performed on stage of course
I've hosted q and A's et cetera you know
I've been on stage in front of a decent
crowd but to have the expectation of
stepping onto a stage where people are
going all right dude make me laugh that
would be an immense amount of pressure
that is very very different to what I
would ever experience in a fight I
admire you guys for what you do honestly
well the experience is similar because
before you go on it doesn't matter how
long you've been doing it really you
there's still an element of nerves or
particularly if you're in the new room
or in a new venue or that you're doing
new material I mean that's the scariest
thing really
um but the process is the same but you
know I was going to ask you because I
mean one of the things that has
obviously happened in our lifetime is at
mixed martial arts has gone from a niche
sport that was only enjoyed and watched
by people who were really really into
fighting uh probably doing it themselves
probably going to when working out at
gyms so now it's it's a mass Sport and
am I right in saying that is basically
the UFC has done that oh yeah absolutely
yeah the UFC of I mean if it wasn't for
the UFC I probably won't be sitting
talking to you guys now I'd probably be
teaching Taekwondo in a in a village
hall in in the Midlands somewhere you
know what the UFC did Dana White and the
frittatas you know they bought a product
which was very very risky at the time a
couple of million dollars you know it
was a very very chaotic thing to try and
find a TV placement foreign and of
course you know things have changed
dramatically now we have all kinds of
all kinds of things that are broadcast
that the silly slap fighting and you
know team MMA all these things would
have been laughed at back in the day
like just to just to have a regulated
mixed martial arts event was a was was a
an alien concept to us but because the
UFC works so hard because they they
brought legitimacy to it they brought
the weight classes and the you know
it just it allowed it to breathe a
little bit it allowed it to find its
foothold and as soon as the foothold was
there it grows it grows so quickly and
it's still growing very very quickly
very I mean it's very impressive and and
I know you've had your issues with Dana
White and maybe we'll talk about it a
little bit but I'm so impressed with
what the UFC has achieved in in in in
the time that I've been paying attention
it's it's incredible what they've done
another thing I don't know if you've
thought about this but I I would I'd be
curious to ask you this question
culturally the world is getting softer
it feels like all the time you know you
can't say this you can't make this joke
like people are getting very sensitive
and yet at the same time you see this
absolutely brutal [__] sport
skyrocketing at the same time and I
can't help thinking there's some sort of
connection between those two things like
the softer people are being made the
more they look for an outlet that's like
raw and hardcore quite possibly quite
possibly I do think that we are kind of
separating as a species I mean the thing
is like
you know you could say all kinds of
stuff when I was a kid you know people
would say all kinds of things and it
would just be kind of oh whatever that's
that's how they talk that's the language
they use Etc but now everything is
looked on looked at under a microscope
but then
back in the day even boxing was
considered to be quite oh hang on a
minute I don't I don't know as I want to
watch Boxing on mainstream TV even
though you know like Nigel Ben Chris
Eubank that was our generation right
they were incredible and and I just
don't feel like I don't feel like boxing
was ever kind of it never it never
bridged that Gap to me like you either
loved boxing or you hated it whereas
mixed martial arts people kind of dip in
they're kind of intrigued because it's
such a broad
um because it's such a broad style you
know you can grapple you can wrestle you
can strike it's quite unknown we have
big characters that likes Conor McGregor
and Ronda obviously she did did wonders
for mixed martial arts
um but I do feel like I mean you know
video games and movies everything's
desensitizing as the violence like we
you know we watch movies now and we're
just not we don't even register what
we're seeing it's so realistic and then
you know obviously like the current War
that's going on like we're watching it
on social media that's never been done
before and we're desensitized to stuff I
see things all the time that if I'd have
seen it as a killer would have been
shocked but now it's just it's a part of
our environment but people are far more
focused on what is being said now as
opposed to what's being done and almost
always what's being done is is far far
worse it's it's a really good point and
but the thing is with UFC is that I find
it that much more brutal than boxing
there are points at UFC where I'm just
like oh my word I just because it's too
visceral but I never really get that
with with boxing even if it's a big
heavyweight match the thing is
for boxing it's quite easy to watch
Boxing unless unless you're there if
you're ringside watching too
heavyweights punching one another like
you you feel that impact like it rattles
through the arena and and it's very
similar to mixed martial arts I mean we
were at an event a little while ago and
there was a it's the only time it's ever
been hap it's ever happened that the
fight was abandoned due to the excess
Blood on the canvas and it was it was a
wild fight Nicholas talby against Ross
Houston on cage Warriors and they beat
the hell out of one another the whole
canvas was just a mess of blood they
couldn't even stand up because it was so
slippy and I was commentating and you
can literally smell the blood in the air
and it's like the whole place gets taken
over it feels like a battlefield but
then at the same time you've got these
two guys that have got a mask of blood
and they're sitting on top of the cage
celebrating they've had such a good
fight so it's I think when when you see
people in those scenarios you kind of
empathize with them but then when you
see how much they love it you kind of go
oh okay like it's kind of what you do I
mean people do all kinds of bad things
to themselves now surgeries and those
kind of things I don't think there's
anything wrong with stepping in there
and testing yourself against another
human being especially when they've
signed on the dot of line to do the same
thing and it is very visceral but I also
feel like it's it's the right
environment for that you know I agree
with you but
the thing is is when you see these types
of fights and you
what's really interesting is then you
find that you see former boxers former
UFC fighters and they find it impossible
to quit and the moment they quit it
seems for a lot of them their life falls
apart like Kell Brook was in the papers
recently we're taking cocaine and a lot
of Fighters
I would have done that during their
career as well but but why is it why is
it that that so addictive
it's almost possible to leave it behind
but because I don't think anything
replicates it you know like Kell Brook
is a is a fantastic boxer but he's never
going to get an adrenaline rush like he
got walking out against Amir Khan
especially because of all the pressure
that was on him for that fight so how do
you go from that height of of excitement
to now I'm retired and then you kind of
drift in because you've always
identified as that person that everyone
sees in the ring you take your gloves
off and you put regular clothes on and
you feel like a regular person and it's
difficult to adjust to that specially
because you've got this fighter this
mentality within you this this this uh
you know war-like atmosphere that's
that's that in your own environment that
you're always experiencing you can step
into a ring and be yourself but then all
the rest of the time you have to kind of
keep a lid on it I think that can be
quite difficult people need that
pressure release and a lot the fighters
that struggle like remember Frank Bruno
going through really troubled times it
like set up a Marquee in his back garden
and was sleeping in a boxing ring and
it's it's the attachment to that
environment that made him feel safe made
him feel himself and like I was in
training camp for a fight was it 2012
um four weeks out from the fight the
doctors in Vegas told me I wasn't going
to be able to compete unless I had a
heart surgery
and straight away I was like I'm kind of
I've been put in a situation where I can
either I can either say no to the the
doctors and try and figure out who I am
outside of mixed martial arts or I can
walk through this surgery and try and
cling to the person that I am and my
mum's I called her outside from the
outside the hospital and she said to me
you would have never stopped anyway like
when what would have stopped you
like it would have taken something like
like a health concern or literally
someone saying no you can't I I would
still fight now if someone sent me a
contract with the right opponent I would
sign it I was supposed to box last year
I was very disappointed that I didn't
get the opportunity to but it's because
I missed that adrenaline rush I missed
that that feeling of being able to get
in there and just kind of
let my Reptilian Brain breather well
this is the point that a Rogan made when
when we were on his show and we were
asking we were talking in Francis you
know he he he's interested and concerned
about the brain injury stuff and you see
it in rugby now you know former uh
England World Cup winners you can't
remember winning the medal and all of
that you know terrible
um but Rogan was like look for some
people it like standing on top of a cage
with 10 000 people screaming as they've
just knocked someone out it's worth it
to them do you are you of that view as
well 100 100 I mean you know if you ask
an Olympic Athlete if they they will
achieve everything they want to achieve
but they'll be dead by 30. most of them
will still do it because the the goal
overrides everything like and we're
we're as Fighters and we're not thinking
about what we're going to feel like when
we're 50. like I've just turned 40. I
wasn't thinking about how I would feel
when I was 40 when I was 20. I wasn't
even thinking I'd make it to 40 at times
because I was just so focused just on do
or die like and I this always seems like
an odd thing to say to people that that
maybe wouldn't have the same kind of
mentality but say before the GSP fight
like I would make sure I paid everybody
back any money I owed if I borrowed a
book or a CD or whatever I'd make sure
they were returned you know I'd make
sure that everything was taken care of
because that 25 minutes is my last 25
minutes and it has to be and because
because otherwise I'm not going to
compete to my potential if I'm not
prepared to give everything wow it's
mate that is very different to how most
people think about it like I didn't
drive here thinking this is the last
hour of my life I gotta give this
interview everything but that's the
nature of what you do isn't it yeah
absolutely I mean you know we see people
do crazy things all the time I mean
those you know those flying squirrel
suits and stuff that your life could be
ended in a second at least I have some
some control over what's going on I feel
you know I can direct the fight as long
as I'm successful and as long as I'm
training hard enough I'm going to be
successful full so the build up and
putting pressure on myself because I'm
putting the work in I'm investing my my
time into doing the right things but
even as you're walking out that moment
right before you step into the optical
right before you walk up the steps you
have a moment to yourself where you're
like
10 12 14 weeks of training camp I've got
15 or 25 minutes to make it happen right
now and that's when your adrenaline
spikes and then Bruce Buffer's there and
he's doing the doing his job and that
gets me fired up as well and you know
you have to kind of bring yourself down
a moment before the fight starts because
you can be Reckless you know you can be
over excited and Reckless and it's
finding that tightrope that you can walk
during the fight where you're you're
trying to be as forthright with your
attack as possible but not be too
Reckless that's a real challenge Floyd
Patterson a former World Heavyweight
Champion used to have a disguise
in his book in his changing room so that
if he lost he could Don the disguise and
slip away and no one would notice do you
do you understand that mentality as a
fighter yeah yeah for sure because you
it's difficult to look at somebody else
in the eye if you feel like you've lost
and you've not lived up to your
potential you know going out there and
giving everything you've got and losing
I never really struggled too much with
that of course I never liked losing but
and as long as I gave it everything I
got like GSP
I couldn't have beat that guy on that
night you know I could have fought him a
hundred times and I probably wouldn't
have beaten him more than a couple of
three times based on where we were skill
wise
that was quite exciting to me because it
felt like there was no pressure all I
had to do was do everything I could in
the fight and it may not have been
enough it probably wasn't going to be
enough but there was a piece that came
with that right like everybody before
the fight said I was going to get
submitted in the first round so
I had already made peace with the fact
that if I have to fight with one less
limb because he snapped it then go ahead
and snap it like people keep coming back
to the arm bar that I escaped in that
fight I don't really think it was that
difficult to not tap because I've
already already decided before the fight
started that I would just punch him with
the other arm
you know it's like we are sacrificing
ourselves when we go in there and and we
you have to be in that mentality I I
don't think you can you can step into
there and think to yourself well I've
got I've got a self-preservation first
because then you're not going to open up
your attack you have to be at peace I
think with with the potential risk that
you're gonna take and what about the
potential risks to your opponent because
there was a very famous fight between
Eubank and Watson where Watson who was
the better fighter many people are came
out of it brain damage and Eubank said
in many interviews that he never hit as
hard as as he could after that was that
never a concern for you of the other
person
honestly no and I think maybe it sounds
a little cold but but if you sign a
contract to step into a cage with me I'm
going to do everything I can to put you
out of there and I'm gonna do it in such
a way where nobody else wants to fight
me ever again like that's the
intimidation factor that Tyson was
talking about and I always say to my
young Fighters now in those last five or
ten seconds of the fight where you know
the fights won and you are looking for
the Finish be as brutal as you can be
because the people sit in front row
might be your next opponent and you want
to give them that fear of God that they
don't want to step in there with you
it's War it can't be anything other if
you treat it like a sport you're going
to lose every time you've got to treat
it like it's Warfare because if you
don't then you're not given the the
environment the respect I feel like it
deserves
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
let's go out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 a simple and easy way to get
all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
a real man we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bird which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Rosenberg if you're looking for a
simpler and cost-effective supplement
routine ag1 is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
travel packs with your first purchase
this go into
athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that's athletic greens.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
and how big is the psychological element
because people I think so often get
confused because you know you get your
CM Punk people types you know people
coming to UFC you know talking in a good
game but they don't have the physical
skill set and they get destroyed but you
know their mentality supposedly is in
the right place and then you get other
people who mentally aren't quite there
even though physically they're very
talented like how how big of a deal is
it managing your mentality I mean that
was one of the things people always said
about Conor McGregor he was very good at
getting under the skin of his opponent
and he was and you know potentially
people would argue in the Jose Aldo if I
you know Alder was so angry at him he
started rushing forward you know and we
saw what happened on the other hand you
piss off khabib
and then things go in a very different
direction yeah for sure I mean you
always need the skills you always need
to put the work in and have the skills
and and
like Conor definitely had the skills to
be Aldo there's no doubt about it but it
would have been a far far more difficult
test had he not primed Jose Aldo to be
so vulnerable right I mean what was that
13 seconds there was no way that Aldo
runs onto a punch like that against
anybody else and and the big difference
with Conor McGregor and a lot of other
people is the way that he commands that
chaos like he he walks into the Octagon
like it's his front room every time and
it doesn't matter who he's fighting
they're there for his benefit and it's
not the other way around and and I feel
like that that can rattle people
sometimes it's certainly rattled out
though like I was remember when he stole
Aldo's belt in Dublin at the uh the
final press conference of the World Tour
I was there at the side of the stage I
knew he was going to do it the security
knew he was going to do it they were
already ready on the stairs to run on
but it was you could just see the Aldo
was so shaken and rattled by Connor
having such a big presence in the room
that no matter what he did it was going
to put Aldo in the wrong mentality for
the fight and again Conor McGregor just
commands chaotic spaces better than
anybody I've ever seen right and even
dealing with the pressure you know like
the the pressure that comes with being a
superstar like we see people like Jon
Jones really struggle with it where
Conor McGregor takes it in his stride
um the mentality is is massive massive
and and I feel like if I mean I've I've
trained with some of the best guys
around and and the two best fighters
that I've trained with the two by a far
in a long way if I put them in the gym
against GSP I would put my money on them
they can't put it together in the cage
because they start to doubt themselves
and their game falls apart but in the
gym with no cameras and no people no
people watching they're they're absolute
monsters and and I always felt like that
was my strength like over some of my
teammates because they sometimes would
get anxious and start to doubt
themselves and and kind of work
themselves out of the fight before it
started I always woke upon fight day
knowing full well that I was going to
win and that they were gonna have to
kill me to stop me and I just I feel
like that made me kind of bulletproof a
lot of the time you know I've only been
knocked out once and I was able to laugh
at it afterwards you know pretty quickly
because it was a silly mistake that I
made and I didn't give my opponent the
credit of of taking that fight from me I
I gave myself the criticism of handing
it over to him because I wasn't in the
right mental state yeah and uh it makes
perfect sense and um you we talked about
Conor McGregor I hope it's not an unfair
question because you know you commentate
on the fights and whatever but as an
outsider as a Layman I can say this or I
can ask this question at least is he
over now is a serious fighter do you
think or does he still have the skill
set to come back and actually compete
you know I think he's definitely got the
skills he's definitely got the skills
and the mentality and just like you know
the likes of Jake Paul he's got the
finances around him to be able to build
the perfect training camp bring all the
right people in to support him
the only downside is that he's a
lightweight and the lightweight division
is probably the most difficult division
in the UFC and and the the Gap in
Conor's game that we've seen him
struggle with is still there like he's
not going to have gained some kind of
like khabib makachev style wrestling
between you know the last time that we
saw him and now and it doesn't seem like
he's been working on it at all but you
put him in there against the majority of
the UFC roster and his presence alone
will rattle them you know like Michael
Chandler who's across him across the
cage from him on The Ultimate Fighter
you know are just engage he's someone
like that they're easy pickings for
Conor McGregor really yeah you think he
can stand up to Michael Chandler and
yeah I do I mean Chandler's Chandler's a
great athlete he moves very very quickly
but since he joined with the UFC he's
been a little more Reckless than he was
in yeah you know like Bellator when he
was knocking out Pitbull and Sydney
Outlaw he was like lightning and that
version he's a very very tough test for
McGregor but McGregor primes people
mentally before he fights them and the
ultimate fight is perfect because you
have to deal with the guy for six or
eight weeks he's going to be poking fun
at Michael Chandler he's going to get
inside his head so by the time the fight
comes McGregor is going to Billy
straight into the octagon with a big
grin on his face and Michael Chandler is
going to be grinding his teeth and just
the difference in mentality is exactly
what we saw from Aldo you know Aldo was
like I'm gonna have to go I'm gonna have
to go he felt like time was passing very
slowly he rushed in he got caught with
the perfect counter you know it's it's
just the way that Conor is able to
command spaces it makes him a very
different different person to deal with
very early like people often forget this
about Ollie because we he's now because
he passed away we've kind of remember
him as this almost saint-like figure but
when he fought particularly Joe Frazier
the things he used to to say the Mind
Games he used to play a lot of the time
when they stepped in the ring Frazier
said it himself he said I think the
words were I want to kill that
[__] yeah yeah absolutely and
that's the perfect mindset to get your
opponents in I I was I used to do quite
a bit of trash talking and and I think I
think it's quite a British thing anyway
like my teammates it's still the same at
the gym this morning I know they're
they're murdering each other with the
trash talk this morning you know as much
as they are with that with their
physical skills and some people just
can't deal with it you know I I thought
a guy Marcus Davis great fighter really
nice guy but just you just couldn't take
the banter and as soon as I'd said a
couple of things and I could see I got
under his skin
straight away I'm feeling like the
fight's swaying in my direction I can
encourage him to fight a particular way
he came out first round guns blazing he
was Furious in the corner so much more
energy is being wasted now this is the
other thing he's like like if he spends
the last three four weeks of training
camp angry and Furious at me he's in a
wake-up every day burning unnecessary
energy he's going to be releasing stress
hormones more than he would be normally
in training camp he's probably not an
arrest as well as he would be would do
normally in training camp and then he
steps in there in front of me and he
sees me across the cage grinning at him
right like and you can watch that fight
back like his Corner Man Mark de la
Grotti was saying to him one more round
you're going to shut this kid up it was
not about beating me it was about
shutting me up and and that for me was
the perfect mentality to have my
opponents in and some people don't
respond like my next opponent Mike
swicky just he just didn't bite on
anything so I just stopped and that made
him quite uncomfortable because he
wanted the banter he felt like that was
that was the way that the fight was
going to be sold
um it doesn't always work McGregor finds
a way to get inside people's minds
regardless of who they are he knows how
to like with Aldo the line about you
know riding into the the favelas in in
Brazil and you know on a horse it was
just it was wild but it's brilliant
because alda's hearing it and thinking
how dare you say that about me you know
but that wildness of character that can
be both an asset and it can be your
weakness as well a great example of that
is Jon Jones who is a wild character
which means he's one of the greatest of
all time but at the same time it's also
his downfall it is absolutely and I
think you know I think we have to
understand that Jon Jones what was he 23
when he got the belt like those first
few fights because I've just recently
done the breakdown for BT Sport on on
the Jones Gan fight coming up and you
know I went back to right the beginning
of his UFC career and watched each fight
through and he was
it makes sense why why he thought he was
he was Untouchable because he kind of
was you know that the things that he was
doing to people spinning elbows from a
from a single leg against Stefan Bonner
people weren't doing those kind of
things think people aren't doing the
same kind of things that McGregor's
doing but the difference is McGregor was
what 26 27 when he was doing them and
Jon Jones was 22-23
I I just feel like he wasn't he wasn't
mature enough to deal with the the
person that he was at the time if that
makes sense but he's still getting into
trouble now he goes to Vegas within you
know half an hour he's assaulted someone
and the police
you know what I mean I wouldn't say it
to his face but you know what I mean
like he's still a wild wild dude which
you know which you can understand I mean
that's probably why he's a fighter
um when is the serial gun uh Jon Jones
fight uh it's a week on Saturday a week
on Saturday
yes well
you're quite high on Jones in terms of
that fight and this is the first he's
gone up to heavyweight which would be
interesting but he's taken his time to
build his body up hasn't he
um is is Francis uh Francis and Gano
versus Jon Jones The Greatest fight the
UFC never made yes it is yeah I I anyone
would see that fight wouldn't they I
mean the only other one that I would say
I would say come I mean obviously
Anderson Silva GSP was a fight people
always wanted but but the Tony Ferguson
khabib fight that never happened you
know of course now people are like I'm
not bothered because we've seen Tony get
beaten pretty convincingly but when they
were trying to make that fight and when
it was made and then fell through
several times I feel like that was the
fight that kind of got away from us yeah
like I I still feel like Jon Jones
technically is leagues ahead of Francis
inganu the the the the you know the X
Factor was the power in in Garner's
hands and whether Jones could deal with
it because like you know we saw him get
clipped with big shots against like
Gustafson and he took them well
and I don't know whether this fight's
the same given the fact that Cyril gun's
not really a puncher either you know
he's a he he kind of has the advantages
that Jon Jones had as a light
heavyweight at heavyweight he moves well
you know he's very he's very disciplined
in his game he's got a great a high
fight IQ good decision making
that in my opinion is quite a tough test
for Jon Jones because it will be a bit
more like fighting the same character in
a video game whereas in Ghana you know
what you have to deal with within Ghana
you have to stay away from that power so
I'm actually more excited for the serial
gamma fight but of course I would like
to have seen the Francis one I I feel
like Francis no matter where he goes
people are going to want to watch
because he's such a unique physical
specimen but Jones is a unique physical
specimen with an immense amount of skill
and creativity and and that's a that's a
very scary thing Francis and Ghana I
remember when he knocked out Rosen
strike and and he he just like takes
this gigantic swing knocks him out the
guy's falling and by the time he's
falling he's hit him another three times
on the way down yeah terrifying and you
know The Knockout over um over Alistair
over him as well where he put his head
back like a Pez dispenser yeah like you
just you know you just don't see that
kind of power on court against people
most of the time and honestly like like
you watch the Overeem fight and you
think to yourself how does he get back
up after that punch I mean he does it's
amazing that he that he gets back to his
feet but there comes a point when you
think to yourself he's gonna hit
somebody one day and they're not going
to get back up and that's kind of that's
Francis and ganu power and I don't feel
like there are many people in mixed
martial arts or even in boxing that have
got that like Deontay Wilde has got a
scary power
you know maybe comparable with inganu
that would be a fight I'd like to see to
be honest but um
it's it's a unique thing but when you've
got someone that's got that kind of
finishing ability and then they back it
up with technique that that's when
they're very very elite and I feel like
Francis is still kind of growing into
that fighter I was a little bit
surprised by how high you are in Jon
Jones and and only like I mean for me
it's a complete Layman by the way I'm
not but he's probably the best fighter
that I've ever seen yeah right present
company accepted obviously but
his last few fights in the light
heavyweight I I mean I personally again
complete Layman I don't know what I'm
talking about but I thought he lost the
Santos fight for example and the others
they they I mean like Reyes was very
close in my opinion so it's not like he
was dominating everybody the way he had
been as you say in his in his early 20s
but you are really you're really
positive on him at the moment you think
he's gonna come come back and and be
really even though we haven't seen him
for a few years yeah I do I do I mean
maybe it's a bit a bit of wishful
thinking because I'm I'm obviously a big
fan of Jon Jones like just going back
and watching his old fights I'm still
I'm still seeing things that I've not
seen before clever little like you know
wrist controls so he's opening up
opportunities to land his elbows on the
ground really clever really clever stuff
very creative as well and and
you see this is where
Jones's last three fights in my opinion
weren't that was him like six out of ten
he looked he looked disinterested he
looked uninspired he didn't look
threatened by his opponents he just he
just didn't really seem to be too
bothered in fact there was an interview
he did recently and he he kind of hints
at the fact that I was fighting Don
Reyes you know he'd been looking forward
to fighting me since he was at high
school you know like it's like I
understand same as Anderson Silva when
he fought Chris Weidman right Anderson
Silva was the champion when Chris
Weidman turned Pro like I I just didn't
see Jon Jones wanting to be in those
fights and plus you know he was having
pay issues and you know feeling
disrespected by the UFC so again things
that are gonna kind of disconnect him
from being there and because he's so
good he can step in there at five out of
ten six out of ten and still beat the
hell out of people you know the
Gustafson fight the first one was a very
very close fight but only because Jon
Jones was out partying and and you know
not not giving Gustafson the respect he
deserves but if he was fighting Francis
inganu just think he'd be out partying
and stuff course not because he'd be
terrified of the person he's facing I
think so I think a bit of fear is
important for Jon Jones and I don't
think we saw it in his last few fights
and I don't I don't feel like they were
close fights because his opponents were
good enough to make them close fights I
felt like they were close because he
just wasn't putting the same kind of
pressure on as he normally does like the
second gust of some fight where he's
trying to wrench his shoulders out of
the sockets and you know takes him down
smashes him on the floor in the third
round
that's a different kind of Jon Jones to
what we've seen and you you know I put
myself in in his mentality I've been out
for three years I've been watching these
heavyweights like make loads of money
and move their way up the rankings no
full well that they're not as good as me
and I'm I'm Jon Jones I'm thinking I'm
gonna come back with a bang I've been
out for three years lifting and getting
strong I think he's gonna come in 250. I
think he might come in the heavier
fighter at the two to be honest wow and
I think he's going to make an example of
Cyril I think that's what his intention
will be and that's a scary Jon Jones
because that's the kind of Jon Jones
that will try and retire you like he's
not like and you know even his post
fight interviews and his last few fights
have been odd you know he puts a
different voice on like the mean Jon
Jones that was fighting Daniel Cormier
that's a person that I don't think
anybody on the planet can be in the
right mentality but the John Jones that
was like you know Anthony Smith I'm so
proud of you
I don't buy that John Jones for a second
I just don't feel like that's his
character he's a mean dude he's nasty
yeah right like the things that he does
he's trying to like Glover to share her
literally trying to wrench his shoulder
out of the socket like you don't see
people doing that in mixed martial arts
he finds the rules the oblique kicks
yeah to the knee to like yeah basically
break the floor and he has no
forgiveness if something works he'll do
it a hundred more times to you until
Until It Breaks you like we we see that
we see that mentality very very rarely
in mixed martial arts which is a shame
because that's kind of where you get the
best fighters but that's why Jon Jones
is a pioneer and do you not think the
fact that he's older now let's be fair
he hasn't really looked after his body
he likes a drink he likes to so he just
called him the extracurriculars do you
think that's not made an impact on him
and his physique
honestly no I don't think so I think
he's such a unique physical specimen I
mean you look at the rest of his family
they're all you know footballers and
that you know he's he's he clearly comes
from from good genetics good good
physical stock so he was always going to
be a good athlete no matter what he did
most athletes when they hit the top of
their game they're always doing stuff
that they shouldn't be doing you know
what I mean and it tends to really
effective yeah yeah
we were watching the Usain Bolt
documentary the other day and he broke
his foot in a nightclub
like training for the Olympics like
fight like because the pressure is so
great people do silly things sometimes
like fortunately I never liked going out
so I never found myself in that in that
circumstance but with Jon Jones like
he's Restless he's full of energy he's a
superstar everywhere he goes people want
to put drinks in his hand and you know
taking places and
yeah of course and you know and
and
it's difficult being a being a a
professional fighter and then going out
in a nightclub because half the people
there because they've had a drink half
the people they think they're your best
friend so their arms around him hanging
on him pulling him in different
directions then you've got the people
that fancy their chances which of course
is not very often with with Jon Jones
but it does happen you know what I mean
you do get those people and it makes the
environment quite difficult and and you
know Jon Jones is used to being
respected if he's got someone that's
drunk that's spitting in his ear or
dragging him around a club or whatever
you know I can imagine he would get
irate with them but he gets high rate
and he's also the most dangerous man on
the planet you know it's it's a
different situation right and do you
think the UFC did enough to keep Francis
in Ghana no absolutely no absolutely not
the request that he made were the thing
that's most disappointing about it is
that nobody else stood by him because
the things he was asking for would
benefit the whole roster you know he was
he was asking for a fighter
representative in in the conversations
that the UFC were having the executive
meetings to make sure that the fighters
were being considered you know these are
things that uh you know people respected
Muhammad Ali for you know standing
against the Vietnam War and you know
refusing to to fight
I know of course that's a that's a
slightly different thing but if we look
at the circumstances in mixed martial
arts right now the pay disputes the
issues with you know Fighters at the end
of their career not having any money not
not really physically being very looked
after by the organization post career
we need people to stand up and make
those changes like the alley act needs
applying to mixed martial arts there's
no doubt about it and Francis inganu
would have been one of the people that
could push that through but he would
have also needed a couple of other
Champions you know he would have needed
an Israel out of San Diego Usman or
someone to stand by him against the UFC
and because he didn't he was kind of he
was kind of shunned and isolated and the
UFC had the power to just kind of push
him to one side well I want to ask you
more questions about the UFC but there
is an elephant in the room here which is
you were you were a UFC commentator yes
and then you left an acrimonious
circumstances and Dana White fired some
shots at you and all the rest so what
happened there
so I mean so I've been working obviously
with the UFC the the UK office for a
long time and as a fighter back in 2008
it was great you know we had a PR team
we had we had a whole office in Old
Street in London it was it was a
fantastic environment really growing
quickly always constantly connecting the
fighters to the media and stuff and it
just felt you know within the time I was
a fighter turned commentator that that
interest in Europe had just kind of
dropped off and my job was an ambassador
for Europe so I was trying to get the
fighters connected to the media I was
trying to make sure that there was
attention and promotion going on around
the UFC and I felt a lot of the time
like I was working hard and there was no
support in in Europe
um and
I I had a there was a particular person
I had a disagreement with who oversaw a
lot of the the public relations stuff
and I always felt like she wasn't
particularly very good at a job didn't
particularly like doing a job I felt
that was that was a big part of the
problem not really interesting mixed
martial arts just kind of doing a job
because that's the job that they do
um but it was starting to get really
obstructive for me you know like so like
BBC Radio contacted the UFC office about
me commentating the mcgregor-porrier
fight and I was initially working for
ESPN on the post-fight desk when this
offer came through it was a great offer
BBC Radio you know broadcasting the
audio for the McGregor fight was a huge
deal for UFC Europe and I definitely
wanted to do it and there was one person
that just kind of stood in the way of it
all and didn't make the connections and
the the there was a point during fire
Thailand where I had a conversation with
this person and I I basically called
called them out on not doing a very good
job and she got embarrassed is is the
best way to put in it I and I understand
at the time why she got embarrassed
because there were a couple of other
colleagues there around us but
I was just so frustrated with the lack
of effort coming from the UK office and
the fact that we had really really great
fighters from Europe that were getting
no attention at all compared to how it
was in 2008 right we want to continue
growing we want to continue the sport
you know reaching into the mainstream
and we were losing ground very very
quickly and that was I was frustrated
with that I I said to the person I said
like why are you not doing your job like
you know you you've got a job to do we
need you to do your job well and you're
just choosing not to do it and I don't
know what was said I don't know what
what conversation was passed on to the
executives in the UFC but it certainly
wasn't the reality of the situation
I never spoke to Dana I haven't spoken
to Dana for a long time normally I would
I would have got a phone call from him
but for whatever reason I didn't hear
from him at all so I don't know what was
sold to the UFC I've still never found
out I can imagine that it was you know
there was a there was a scenario created
that wasn't wasn't the truth and I feel
like that's kind of the situation that I
was caught in well the way Dana
presented in one of his interviews was
that you'd you'd mistreated one of the
female employees that's how he first yes
yeah which is which is hugely insulting
if anyone knows me they just know I'm
not that kind of person you know of
course we're discussing before we
started
yeah
but the reality is it's like I
understand what Dana's up against
because I'm getting treated like he's
being treated now but he was caught on
video and that's not my responsibility
that was from sparring you know what I
mean I understand that
he said his punishment was how people
will view him absolutely for sure but at
the same time he's a powerful man and
he's got a lot of money and he's he's
able to kind of Coast past these things
and throw shots at me which were false
there were lies of course I'd never
mistreated anybody all right well coming
back to the UFC itself then so we've got
that out of the way so people can make
their own minds up about how objective
but there's been a lot of talk about
fighter pay and I again complete Layman
so I I'm probably talking [__] but just
hear me out as a just an outside
Observer on the one hand I see that most
other leagues have some kind of Union
representation or some kind of you know
the NBA for example they collectively
bargain to get more money on the other
hand the counter argument from people
like Dana is well look we invest in the
sport and we grow it so we have you know
performance institutes we are constantly
trying to Source new Talent we're
building the entire sport not just for
the UFC but for other promotions because
we're pushing all this stuff forward
where we've built a mainstream following
for what used to be a niche product and
you know that that's why we need the
money essentially right what I mean
you're a former fighter and you have to
be you've left the EOC so I imagine
where you land on it but what do you
make of his counter argument essentially
well there's no there's certainly
nothing we can take away from the UFC
what they've done for the sport and the
you know the the industry that they've
created for all fighters but we also
can't forget that the industry wouldn't
be there if it wasn't for the fighters
as well now the UFC are making massive
massive amounts of money right and then
you've got fighters that are retiring
with nothing in their bank account and
it's not because they're not managing
their finances very well it's because
they might fight twice a year and they
might get twenty thousand dollars if
they fight
perfect per fight right yeah but then
they've got to pay for their camp and
coaches yeah transport I mean training
camps are incredibly expensive just you
know travel and gym fees you know all
fighters have to contribute to their gym
they have to pay management teams
the other the other thing that affected
us massively was the sponsorships being
taken off the table so when I first
joined the UFC you could bring your own
shorts you had to supply two pairs of
shorts you had to show them what
sponsors you had in case there were any
conflicting sponsors with the UFC's main
sponsors but otherwise you were able to
represent the companies that you wanted
we had the banners behind us in the
corners we had all of our sponsors on
the banners and stuff that was all taken
away so say when I thought Joseph my
purse was was twenty two thousand
dollars for that right and I'm this is
I'm fighting in a world title fight
on a pay-per-view then what six million
people watching something like this was
quite a long time ago it was it was for
sure they were different dollars too
absolutely but but even so the money
that I should have made then based on
what was being made of the fight
even if the even if the fighters were
being paid that today like Paddy pimlers
uh high up on the UFC cards in London
but he's still getting paid the same as
what people were getting paid 10 years
ago it's it's it's it's embarrassing
that it's not progressed through and
that money's going somewhere like the
all the sponsors were taken away from
the fighters so say Vito Belfort was
sponsored by Sky he got two million
dollars a year or something from them
that was taken away straight away
so then then a lot of Revenue dries up
for Fighters and then of course the UFC
then bring their own sponsors in so now
crypto pay the UFC 175 million and the
fighters get none of that right or the
Reebok deal like I I would have got
fifteen thousand dollars off tap out or
two thousand dollars off Reebok if my
time had been different and and you're
talking five or ten years difference
so surely things should get better
things were good and they got worse
because the UFC drew the money back into
their own Pockets like the first thing
would like first thing we had relatively
free sponsorship market then there was a
tax that was brought in so if you wanted
to sponsor a UFC fighter it was
somewhere between fifty and a hundred
thousand dollars for your company to pay
to the UFC so that money then didn't go
to the fighters so then it all if you've
got a hundred companies that's then
reduced down to 10 companies that can
afford the hundred thousand dollars to
the UFC and then a hundred thousand
dollars of their budget's already gone
to the UFC and they've got pennies left
to pay the fighters
like so we kind of went through the the
money being taken off the table and then
the UFC purse is not increasing
it's it's the money's being made in
massive amounts and it's not being fed
back into the the Grassroots of the
sport and the guys that are retiring now
are the guys that are going to open gyms
and train the next generation of
Fighters like we're training the GB top
team for my wife's training camp Brad
Pickett it's an awesome gym but it's the
only one in the country that's like it
and it still was a lot of money to set
up and Brad didn't have all the money to
set it up himself like we need this
money to become back to come back to the
fighters so we can keep growing the
industry but at the moment it's got to
the stage where now all of the creams
being scraped off the top into a few
accounts and everybody else is is making
the money for the few people that are
benefiting which ultimately is the
situation in most Industries right yes
you know across the world it's the same
so but it sounds like you feel that you
know the UFC is in a monopolistic
position and it's taken advantage of
that 100 we you've got to remember like
when I was when I was coming through I
had the options of fighting on UFC on
Elite XC strike 4 dream Pride Bow Dog
there were loads and loads of events
that were options for us but then we see
eventually the UFC buys up all of these
organizations so they're by elitex scene
they buy Strike Force they buy Pride so
then basically you've not got all your
boutique coffee shops and you've not got
your you have several different strong
Brands you've got one brand that charge
three or four times the amount for the
same cup of coffee and you've got no
other options to go anywhere else so do
you want to fight for the UFC and get
paid twenty thousand dollars or do you
want to go and fight for
the show down the road and get 500 plus
ticket sales like it there was just no
option like you either sign with the UFC
or you're not a professional MMA fighter
and that was kind of how it was
monopolized and that was during during
my time as a UFC fighter as well you
know they were being investigated by the
FBI for not monopolizing the industry
and and stuff and
we were told as Fighters don't speak to
anybody don't speak to anybody about
this monopolization of the sport because
they knew they were doing it it was a
very very clever mechanism to to slowly
squeeze out the competition like Pride
was awesome it was a massive Japanese
event they bought it for 30 million they
brought all the fighters over and then
the fighters are the whim of whatever
UFC wants to pay them they monopolize
the sport so there's no other options to
go anywhere else I can't negotiate like
I could if I was a a free agent in
boxing I could go work and go Eddie
Hearn or I could go Frank Warren or I
could speak to the zone or whatever I've
got options with the UFC you can't if
you want to be the best in the world you
have to sign with the UFC because there
are no other options you know now
obviously with the pfl coming through
the industries in another stage where
it's growing money's coming back into
the sport but that's probably because
the UFC are losing a bit of momentum I
think why are they losing momentum
I think a big part of it I mean Dana is
the driving force behind it and he's
kind of he's kind of taken his eyes off
the off the prize to me you know he's
like the UFC is constantly promoting the
power slap League he's forgetting the
main event Fighters names like you
forgot macachev's name twice in the
build up to UFC 284. how can you do that
if you're the promoter I I feel like
he's lost interest in it and I feel like
now because he feels like he's
Untouchable he's just going to ride it
till the wheels fall off and make as
much money as you can what do you make
about slap because uh I'm a big fan of
the UFC I think I understand what you're
saying but at the same time I can see
the incredible job Dan has done to build
it up to what it is and build the sport
I'd love to interview him we were going
to interview him the last time he was in
London and if we get a chance I'll put
some of these questions to him as well
the points that you're making but when I
look at slap
again casual don't know what I'm talking
about I'm sort of like going wait like I
understand people hitting each other and
being able to defend each other but this
is just people hitting each other
just with no protection is that really a
sport
well what do you make of it it's
dangerous it's very very dangerous now
now
I I went through I went through the
years where the UFC where mixed martial
arts wasn't accepted so I had a lot of
people telling me that I shouldn't be
doing what I was doing because they
didn't understand it so I'm trying not
to project my opinions onto powerslap as
the thing in itself my main issue with
it is that it's so closely tied to the
UFC like we fought for years and years
when I fought GSP was it was 2010 it
wasn't that long ago
most of my interview questions were
about MMA why should it be a legitimate
sport I had people throwing the words
cop fighting at me and stuff I'm like I
am a professional athlete I train all
day every day I am working on my skill
set I'm working on my my physical
conditioning my sports psychology I
don't drink I'm dedicated with my diet
and you're treating me like I'm a thug
it's not fair because I was dedicated to
a sport but then
so much time has passed and I guess I
guess in in a way it reflects how strong
the UFC brand is that now they can stick
power slap on the side of it and don't
feel like they're doing damage to the
sport if you'd have done that in 2010 it
would have completely invalidated the
UFC as a brand because people were still
on on the fence about it but now again I
feel like Dana feels like he's
Untouchable because they are ramming the
power slap League down our throats I've
unfollowed Dana and the UFC on Instagram
because I'm sick of seeing it popping up
I go on Fight Pass because I'm
researching fights and it's there on the
front page so it's a lining basically
two guys just taking three swings at one
another like it's just it's CTE for
money like they're trading brain cells
for cash and they're only offering you a
couple of thousand dollars to do it
anyway it's not like it's not it's not
like it's going to change your life I
mean it change your life for the
negative of course be drinking out you
know eating eating soup for the rest of
your life doing that kind of stuff
it misses the point of Combat Sports
it's not a sport because there's not a
competitiveness to it it's the person
that can get up after taking full power
slaps
that's that in my eyes is ridiculous the
art of martial arts is the attack and
the defense right you don't get scored
defensive mixed martial arts scoring
criteria because the defense is the
rewarding itself right you keep your
hands up you don't get punched in the
face well done you right the idea of
power slap is that you stand there and
you take a shot you know it's common
that's just free CTE for everybody
involved and and and because it's bolted
onto the UFC now so so tightly all the
way through their social media and and
their their online presence and
everything if something happens to one
of those people
of course it gets reflected badly on the
UFC but I just don't feel like they care
anymore and that's what that's the
problem I have with it and so who are
these people taking part in power slaps
because it comes up on my phone and like
I say I really enjoy UFC huge boxing fan
and I'm it just I I don't like it I'm
not sure how many people who watch UFC
or boxing would be into that well I mean
if you look at the the comments on the
USC's social media anytime Dana or the
UFC posts something literally every
single one of the comments with
thousands of likes is stop showing us
this we don't want to see it it's of
course there's a market for it but but
there's a market for everything
unfortunately these days if you put two
people in vehicles and got them to drive
one another in that'd be [__] popular
this is the direction we're going right
yeah what we watched idiocracy last
night I'm I'm watching that movie
thinking to myself we are moving into
this time in our lives where
people are just so stupid they their
appetite for things is is is awful
I just feel like something terrible is
going to happen at some point and it
disappoints me to see the likes of
forest Griffin that was a big player in
solidifying the UFC as a brand catching
these dudes as they're falling on the
floor and and who are these guys like
you said they're probably guys that if
they're not doing this they're doing
another job that they hate so they might
as well get a bit of Fame and a bit of
Fortune and maybe you know a couple of
trips to Vegas and wants to slap around
the face to a guy that doesn't care much
about his life anyway I just can't get
into the mentality of it I really
struggle to understand it yeah it's to
me it's something that I the only people
who would be into it is if you have a
gratuitous love of watching people
getting hurt
that to me is is the only real upshot of
that sport because there's no real skill
involved in it
no none at all not at all I mean you you
literally stand and wait to receive the
shot but the thing is like this is where
we are I suppose degrading a little bit
as a species because there is an
appetite for that you know like this
like there's this hunt sabotages going
on up and down the country at weekends
because people are still trying to Fox
Hunt like come on you know what I mean
like like taking pleasure in something
else's pain is an odd and and sick
mentality I think like when I'm watching
martial arts I'm not going oh man that's
a that's a that's a bad elbow get him
again get him again with that I'm
appreciating the elbow as a striking
weapon but I'm also appreciating the guy
on the bottom trying to defend that
elbow and what he's trying to do to get
out of it if you if you turn mixed
martial arts into Power slap and you've
got two people to walk into the center
of the cage and just take one shot after
the next at one another with no defense
like that would never have become a
legitimate sport back in 1995 or 2005 or
whatever
do you think this is where Tick Tock
meets Combat Sports so
do you see what I mean because in 40
seconds you watch someone get slapped on
the floor and then
pass out or whatever and then you move
on to the next one yeah and and that is
it is it is that 15 second attention
span isn't it you probably remember when
uh when the you've been Tangoed adverts
came out and they had to ban them
because kids were walking up to one
another and tangoing each other at
school and his kids were like oh this is
a bit of fun I've seen it on TV slap
like people were genuinely getting hurt
doing that at school I remember a couple
of kids had to go to the hospital
getting slapped unconscious like suck up
sucker slaps we see that on on
social media all the time now we're just
moving in a direction that that I feel
like we should be a bit more conscious
of and I don't feel like power slap is
helping in any way all right well we've
flagged off the years enough
um he's still one of my dream guests and
I'd love to talk to him about this stuff
because you have a fantastic
conversation with him he's a very very
interesting what he's he's achieved but
uh this is probably going to come up in
one of his press conferences and we're
all going to be in the firing line
um you know one of the things I think
makes MMA incredibly exciting and this
is actually something that Dana has
talked about which is you never know
what the outcome is going to be if you
watch man you play stevenage it can be
exciting but generally speaking man
you're gonna man you're it's gonna be
four nail and there's going to be a bit
of a boring game
but look at I mean and this is a British
fighter who was a champion in the UFC
now Leon Edwards right fighting Kamara
Usman who again as an outsider was much
better on the night and and probably is
a better fighter some people would argue
five rounds Leon is struggling most of
them he's still doing gray I mean he's
fighting and doing great but by around
five you're going look I mean you've
done you've done a really good job
you've done your best maybe but Kamara
Usman is the true champion blah blah
blah blah blah and then one kick and it
and in his Champion just like that that
I think is the thing that makes it so
exciting is you just don't know who's
gonna win
and like you said you had to punch his
chance against JSP who again you thought
was a better fighter than you yeah for
sure he absolutely was he was a better
fighter than Matt Sarah but Matt Sarah
landed that punch that you know that
that opportunity yeah it is a very very
chaotic sport very crazy sport to try
and predict my predictions for fights
are so terrible
because generally I've realized that
over the past few years doing the the
pigs podcast and stuff it is like I I
kind of what I realized is I I always
side with the underdog and I kind of get
drawn into a possible narrative like Jon
Jones coming back as the greatest
heavyweight of all time I'm fully on
board with that narrative and I feel
like it could possibly happen but it
also might not like Cyril gang might
come out and take him down and you know
pin him from top position being a big
strong heavyweight that's improved his
ground game since the Francis and ganu
fight and he might dominate on the floor
and that would be a huge surprise just
as it was a surprise when Francis inganu
came out and did it to Cyril people
didn't expect him to do it like you can
never predict what's going to happen in
mixed martial arts and be 100 certain
anyone that bets on it I think he's
crazy because
it just seems like an easy way of
throwing money out the window to me
because you just literally never know
what's going to happen like it's one of
the reasons why it's exciting of course
is the unpredictability but you also got
to remember like your analogy with
Manchester United is the same with
boxing right if you see Canelo fight the
majority of the time you expect him to
beat them fairly soundly and and
probably stop them and and if we look at
what's most likely going to happen well
he's either going to knock him out he's
going to stop him on Cuts or he's going
to beat him by decision
that's three options in mixed martial
arts how many options are there right
you could get caught with the flying
knee just as you can get caught with a
flying arm bar you can get taken down
and hit with an elbow you can get taken
down and submitted you can get kicked in
the head you can get choked out it there
are so many ways to lose in mixed
martial arts that it's difficult to
predict how someone's going to win and
that for me is why it's so exciting and
we also don't know what's going on in
people's training camps like what has
Jon Jones been doing for three years you
know has he been working really really
hard on his leg locks you might come
back as a leg lock specialist but he's
kept it quite tight to his chest and not
told anybody I I love the fight that
makes martial arts is so open-ended when
it comes to the fights and and and I
accept the fact that I'm gonna have a
good idea of what I think might happen
and be completely proven wrong when it
comes to Saturday night yeah it's
exciting and it is and you mentioned the
sort of rooting for the underdog and I
again as an outside I keep saying but I
just I don't want people to think that
I'm like I think I know what I'm talking
about but watching um the volkanovsky
fight recently and I was talking to
Rogan about this because he did this
fight companion and they were all said
in volkanovski had won
uh and I was like I think most people
thought he'd won because he was the
underdog and they wanted him to win
if you looked at objectively I think it
was a very close fight actually that
um what's his face uh makachev is
Islamic I wouldn't say that to his face
either
uh actually probably edged for me uh but
it's that excitement isn't it of like
rooting for the underdog hoping that he
can win as well absolutely and you know
I agree I feel like Michael Chev won the
fight and I feel like vulcanovsky knew
that matchev won as well like in his
post-fight interview you know he
mentioned about the fact that he left it
too late I feel like now vulcanovsky
knows that he can beat makichev if he
gets the rematch but I feel like he he
felt beaten on the night I feel like Max
ever done enough to beat him he did he
didn't feel beaten up but he feel he was
defeated there's no doubt about it in my
eyes but I do think in the rematch
volkanovsky's gonna have a lot more
confidence based on that first fight and
I do think it would be a different a
difference is it going to be a rematch I
think so I think so and I think because
obviously Joe Rogan's got such a huge
voice in the sport the fact that he said
he thought one and then the fact that
Vault came out afterwards and was like
yeah I won three rounds no doubt like
just creating that narrative gets you a
bit closer to the opportunity and for
sure I think you'll get his opportunity
again Dan top five fighters who are they
and why oh in just mixed martial arts in
just some Mixed Martial so we can do
boxing as well but let's just stick to
mixed martial arts for the moment and
then we can do boxing afterwards we've
got to put Jon Jones up there I'm very
much feeling like he might be the
greatest talent that we've seen in the
sport so far
um Conor McGregor you have to say just
purely because of how he took command of
the the divisions that he was in he
changed the sport for the benefit of
everybody
um and I mean the the composure that he
showed in high pressure situations where
he really shouldn't win was was unlike
anybody else I've ever seen
after that I mean Jose Aldo is always is
always one of my favorites you know you
look back at his fights when he was in
the wec before he came over became UFC
champion he was just he was just
spectacular every single range Jose Aldo
is fantastic at and again you know if
you thought McGregor a couple more times
I feel like he'd have probably beaten
him a couple of times but the
circumstance of that first fight was was
so perfect for McGregor that Aldo was
overextended but it takes away from the
fact that Aldo is probably one of the
best fighters that we've ever seen and
Demetrius Johnson as well you know
another fighter
uh after that it's difficult because
because there are lots of Fighters that
have had a big impact on the sport but
maybe not have been the best fighters
like Randy Couture had such a massive
impact BJ Penn had a massive impact but
you put them in mixed martial arts now
and we can see how far behind they are
even with GSP you know GSP was was great
for 2010 when he came back and fought
Bisping that you know he was a great
version of himself but I feel like
Fighters are better now I do just
generally I feel like there are
wrestlers that can deal with GSP now and
I feel like you striking was not
necessarily where it needs to be to
compete in mixed martial arts today so
it's important to recognize the fighters
to be that were great in the time that
they were great no she didn't mention
Anderson Silva
you know Anderson Anderson was always
one of my favorites I learned so much
from him but I always felt like Anderson
was a was he was a kickboxer in mixed
martial arts like and I know he had that
that triangle over chaosun which I still
watch back and squint my eyes at it
sometimes
Anderson was great but I never felt like
he hit that that well-roundedness that I
would like to have seen from a from a
you know one of the all-time greats Jon
Jones can do it everywhere you know
Valentina chefchenko can fight you
anywhere she's incredible you know what
I mean and that for me that's what I'm
looking for and I I do to us to an
extent shelves the the personal stuff as
well like am I looking for a model human
being I'm not if I am I'm not looking at
Jon Jones but if I'm looking at the best
talent that we've ever seen in mixed
martial arts I can't think of anyone
that comes close to him compete
yeah
see this is where I get loads that's
where I get loads of heat in the
comments khabib was amazing at wrestling
but I never saw him really step too much
outside of what he was very very good at
like his striking was was all right it
was effective at times but it was
effective because he's wrestling was so
good right like the shot that he landed
on McGregor the overhand he would have
never landed that in a kickboxing match
because McGregor wouldn't be expecting
the takedown so it's circumstantial
right and the other thing as well is
like you look at the like I think Jon
Jones's last what 12 fights have all
been World title fights like khabib
didn't defend his belt too many times
and it's probably the right thing to do
because the likes of Charles Oliveira
are coming through could have quite
easily been you know been the person to
catch him
I feel like microchair is probably going
to do the same thing right he's probably
going to defend his belt once maybe move
up to well to wait and fight there once
and then retire I like the fighters that
stick around long enough to experience
their their defeats well speaking of
getting
um getting hate in the comments uh that
I had a very controversial thought the
other day which was is it possible that
makatov is actually better than Habib
because he is more rounded his striking
is really good uh and like you say
khabib was able to strike with people
because everyone was terrified of
getting taken down they had to worry
about that so much whereas macachev has
both he has incredible wrestling and he
can strike and we saw that with
vulcanovski didn't we yeah I I think
Maca Chevy is definitely the the Mark II
version of of uh of khabib and honestly
I feel like that was I feel like that
was Father's plan you know they talk
about that about abdominal apps plan I
always feel like he saw macachev as
being the you know the second comment of
khabib khabib served the purpose of
establishing that team being dominant in
the lightweight division remaining
undefeated which of course it makes
martial arts is very difficult again if
people stay around for long enough
though they don't keep that undefeated
record because there's always somebody
who makes martial arts that can beat you
and I feel like khabib did the right
work to get that team's
presence in the sport to a point where
makachev can then step in and take over
as the the better version and I do feel
like he is the better version for sure
certainly in the Striking ranges like
he's a he's a very very strong South
Pole he's got a great left kick we've
seen his boxing improved in the Oliveira
fight as well I see big improvements
from macachev but again a controversial
opinion the reason why microchip
striking is good is because he's got a
loss on his record by knockout right if
he did not got knocked out earlier in
his UFC career he wouldn't have taken
the time to really refine his striking
like he did right my wrestling wouldn't
have improved had I not been taken down
and dominate on the floor so many times
right you react to the stimulus that you
get so undefeated Fighters they never
really reach their full potential
because they never explore their full
potential in my opinion and what do you
make of this uh the YouTube fighter
shall we say because there's a lot of
people you know the boxing purists the
fight purists a lot of boxers who get
really upset at it because they're like
well I've trained all my life I'm
brilliant at what I do I don't get a a
tenth of the money I don't get the
nearly any of the Acclaim this isn't
fair
gotta learn from it haven't you you've
got to learn from it like there's
clearly something like Jake Paul was
clearly doing something right right he's
built an audience his audience of of uh
attached himself to him they're along
for his journey they're not bothered
whether he's a boxer he could be an
American football player or a downhill
skier or whatever he wanted the people
that are following him are there for his
journey that's what he did right he
connected to her to an audience and and
and and allowed them to understand the
life that he's living so any boxers any
people that are complaining about it are
not understanding the the research that
he's done for them like make yourself
available to the fans that's ultimately
Wise Wise making good money is because
he's taking people along on the journey
with him and he's had these people that
have grown up since he was on the Disney
Channel right so they've been on his
journey all the way along he just so
happens to be a boxer now they don't
care whether he's a boxer or not the
boxing community care whether he's a
boxer or not but why because he's making
loads of money
a proposal for you mate when we get two
minutes
it's funny because actually this is this
is the situation quite often in comedy
as well but you've got comedians who are
grinding away on the circuit for years
and years and years and they're very
good at what they do stand up and then
they see some guy you know uh Mo
Gilligan is a good example of this
someone who just did stuff online and
now he's massive and they're like oh
he's not a real comedian you go he's got
a million followers and you're playing
the Dog and Duck on a Thursday night to
20 people what the [__] are you talking
about you know
um Dan it's been an absolutely
fascinating conversation thanks so much
for coming on big fan of your breakdowns
particularly on full reptile because as
you say you don't always get the
predictions right but I actually think
this is why UFC commentary and Analysis
or MMA commentary and Analysis I should
say is such a big Niche now and it's
growing and you're doing it and Charles
sonen is doing it a bunch of other
people are doing it because for the
Layman we don't understand a lot of what
you know once it hits the ground you're
like oh what's he doing there but
explaining the mechanics of the sport
and why people are doing certain things
it's invaluable I'm a big fan of yours
big fan of your channel thank you so
much for coming on
um before we let you go as you know we
always finish with the same question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
um that is a good question to finish on
we're not talking enough about the
people that are taking advantage of us
as a society
ultimately like there are a few people
online but YouTube censorship is
terrible right now online censorship is
terrible right now no matter what social
media platform you're on there are
there's a small number of people taking
advantage of the vast majority of the
Earth's population and we just we don't
talk about it we don't seem to talk
about it we try and talk about it then
we get shut down and there's a lot of uh
I wish I had a better word but [__]
is the only one I can I can think of in
politics in business in every industry
there are a few people that are taking
advantage of everybody and and we just
don't say anything we just don't say
anything because it's the same within
the UFC if you say something you get
your media credentials taken away you
get your opportunities taken away if you
speak out about the UFC you get your
opportunity you know what I mean it's
like there's mechanisms to shut people
down and everybody is treating uh is
acting like they've already been shut
down before they've even spoken like we
need to start speaking out against
against the the corruption that we're
seeing in our world I feel like that's
not being taught about enough it's it's
present on a daily basis in my eyes and
and it's people try and ignore it and
just get on with their lives and we
can't can you give us more detail like
who who are you talking about well I
mean obviously you have a lot of people
that you know that follow your podcast
due to the political stuff that you talk
about I mean you look at the PPE Scandal
that's going on at the moment you know I
follow one of my favorite YouTubers is
Dr John Campbell if you don't listen to
him everybody should listen to him the
things that he's in uncovering on a
daily basis like people are lying to us
are people are lying to us and and
slowly killing us off as well in lots of
different ways whether it's pollution or
global warming or medicine or whatever
you know what I mean like I feel like I
mean the pandemic was a big like that
was a big wake-up call I think for a lot
of people absolutely well it's like
you're being told stuff and you're going
well three years ago you said that was
Mars don't work now they work all of a
sudden absolutely when did that happen
right and then and then we we go from
celebrating the NHS and thanking their
hard work and their diligence and their
dedication to their their job and then
the media then starts to turn us against
them because they're striking because
the NHS is under attack
the NHS is definitely under attack it's
you know it's being defunded so they can
sell it off private and privatize it and
that's going to affect every single one
of us like the the NHS kept my
granddaughter alive for many many years
and I've I've traveled all around the
world I've lived in the US I've lived
without uh free healthcare
it's not it's not a world that we want
to live in like we don't we just we
don't want to live in a country that
charges people when they're sick like
you're not you're not sick you're a
customer and that's a terrifying
circumstance to put people in like cost
of living crisis is a terrible phrase
awful phrase the cost of living like
we're trapped in a framework right now
that we are we are not even aware of
struggling to get out of it and not
enough people are talking about it in my
eyes
Dan thank you so much for coming on the
show it was an absolute pleasure if
people want to find you online if they
want to see your work where is the best
place to do that well YouTube you can
just search my name Dan Hardy or I'm on
social media Dan Hardy MMA Instagram and
Twitter and wherever else I'm uh
I'm always under the same name and
everyone should check out full reptile
your YouTube channel as well before we
let you go uh your better half is here
we talked about all the bruises on our
face and stuff but she's about to fight
in in the UFC here in London yes tell us
about her because she's I think first up
on the card so people can check her out
early in the night yeah well Veronica
macido is what people will know as but a
new name is nav Veronica Hardy we've got
marriages Before Christmas
um so this is the first fight back after
three years out she's been working
through some injuries and she's tipped
top and strong right now and she's going
into UFC London March 18th so we're very
very excited for her very different for
me to be going to UFC London and not
think somebody's gonna punch me in the
face a bit more pressure to be on the
outside watching somebody trying to
punch her but she's very well prepared
and I'm excited for her and is it as a
man is it a bit weird to see your woman
like fighting and getting punched in the
face is there a part she's obviously a
professional fighter and you knew that
but is there like a weird thing going on
there is that difficult
um because you you've got I imagine God
protective instincts you want to that's
what you're supposed to do right
absolutely yeah absolutely it's weird
watching sparring sometimes because I do
want to get in there and kind of
sometimes you know a bit two-on-one is a
bit unfair but
um it is weird it's more strange the the
the reactions I get from other people as
we're walking down the street if she has
got a black eye or you know a bruise or
whatever because people obviously
immediately assume that it's I'm
responsible for it and you know she's
she's sparring hard with good Fighters
at the moment so you're gonna get bumps
and bruises and stuff and that's that's
a new challenge for me because it for me
it was always I'm fighting I've got
bruise on my face so people don't really
question it or I'm with my friends and
they're all fighters and they're all
male and no one really questions it you
know but a a female fighter they do get
a different uh different interactions
with the public you could say yeah well
Dan thanks so much for coming on uh it's
been an absolute pleasure everyone
should check out your YouTube channel
for reptile and find you on all the
socials uh thank you we'll ask you a
couple of questions from our local in a
second that only they will get to see
but for now thank you thank you for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
uh won't be quite like this but we'll be
as equally brilliant and take care and
see you soon and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
for someone who's never followed MMA or
the UFC what would you say would be a
good intro to to see if that you're
interested in it
[Music]